all right it's 5 46 hey all this week
also where a pair of restaurants are
sharing some simple dishes that you can
make at home to get ready for the super
bowl for big game grub this morning
heading back into seoul belly barbecue
in downtown las vegas for the ultimate
seven-layer dip
back again with a chef bruce from soul
belly barbecue here in the arts district
now you're making something a lot of us
think we know which is the seven-layer
deck seven-layer dip yeah this one this
one's fancy it's a little fancy you know
i'm trying to stick with the barbecue
theme here a little bit uh the great
thing about seven layer dip is
all you need is seven layers just pick
seven things you like right okay so this
is a refried bean i made out of our
baked beans actually oh so like you can
do refried beans you can buy refried
beans at the store
you could buy you know canned baked
beans and make a puree
you know either way which is basically
what we did
with our texas ranch beans so i like
putting that one down first
it's kind of a heavy layer you want to
always try to do a glass dish so you can
see the layers now this is the pimento
cheeks that we made yep that's right so
i like using this again the flavor
profiles is cool it's unique
works really well with everything else
you could do like literally a um
like a taco seasoned sour cream a lot of
people do things like that
but for me this is a little a little bit
better cross-utilizing ingredients it's
a big chef thing
you know because you want to keep things
efficient in a restaurant and so if you
have something really good
why not why not use it you know all
across the board on your dishes and then
we're going to go with some guacamole
gotta have the guac
and this one i just made a little more
neutral than a typical guacamole more
like an avocado mash got it
now the key to keeping it from going
brown is what that that lime juice yeah
you need the acid to keep it from
oxidizing now we do our garnishes so
we've got some cheddar cheese
this is number four here's some pico de
gallo now this is interesting i've seen
black olives before but i don't think
i've seen green ones i like these and it
goes you know with the mementos it goes
kind of pairs well with the pimento
cheese dip
and then we're going to top it with some
scallions
why not serve it with some
chicharron
some tortilla chips
something you made yeah a little extra
special here from soul belly something
you can buy too perfect chef bruce this
looks amazing here let's take a dip
gonna be delicious
hey the key right you got to get all the
way down in there yeah you got to fish
your way down
[Music]
almost needed a spoon for that one you
can find this recipe all the big game
grub online at 8newsnow.com and tomorrow
we're going to head back to distilling
remedies for another very simple dish
that's elevated a little bit that you
can make for your super bowl party yes
you hungry yet a seven layer dip seems
complicated because you don't just have
the one layer right but you've got six
more beyond that but if you just sort of
flatten them out and do your thing right
and if you have chips nearby you're good
to go pimento cheese but remember it was
not guacamole that was avocado mash
exactly
because guacamole is kind of in too many
flavors right with the pimento cheese
yeah
the other six layers don't have all of
that
i never did mine in a bowl where you
could see it i always did it in like a
flat dish so i like pretty right where
you can see all the layers
just the proof of your seven layers you
need to see proof of otherwise who knows
thank you chef bruce jerry let's talk
weather
seven